[音楽]
分
ん
こんにちは竹内解雇です
今日はいい
夢を持たずに夢を叶える方法というテーマでお話させて頂きたいと思います
私は平安伸銅工業という会社の社長しています
この会社なんてをしている会社かといいますと
皆さん私の手元にあるこれ
御存知ですか
皆さんも家にも一つぐらいあるのではないでしょうか
このネジくひーランドで収納を倍増できるアイデア商品
すっぱりぼこれをつくっている会社です
この商品私の双眼140連敗にアメリカからと近い日本で普及させた商品になります
サイズは小さいもので13cm
大きいものでは3メートル近くあるんですね
本省にいろんな種類がありまして
例えばコレだっとっ
だいたい80キロがかけられるんですね
提出しちゃダメですよ
さらにですね包帯とかなぁ
反応タイプ様々なものがありまして
私たちの会社ではこの突っ張り棒で200種類以上の品川へ思っています
私はこの会社を20102010年にこの会社に入りました
入社後なんですけれども
この会社ピーク時は1995年後10億近いいや気があったんですが
私が入る前年にはなんと108区まで
土産が下がっていました
その状態からなんとか新しい商品を開発したり社内の体制を改革したりして
この8年間で22奥まで売上を持ち直すことができました
ように経営者として日々会社の発展のために取り組んでいるのですか
私これ以外にもやっていることがあります
プロフィールでもあったと思うんですけどもやっぱり強かっ
これ何かといいますと
これテレビ公共さんで取材頂いた時の写真です
突っ張り棒の正しい取り付け方や突っ張り棒の新しい使い方
魅力を
テレビ雑誌新聞などを通じて発信しています
もう一つ私やっていることがありまして後継者のゴールもで
というのがあります
これはですね
今日本では
後継者不足で廃業する中小企業が増えて社会問題になっています
九尾狐上げてそれを防ごうということで私のように自動も強みを生かしながら新しい
ことに挑戦している会社
これを上げて発信していきます
その後ロボてるとして私が振り上げていただいてまして
経産省のホームページこのような形で私のクリ君が掲載されています
その他にこれは
関西大学での授業なんですなぁ
作業を持っている学生さん向け
か行どうか病とはなんぞやということを教える
蝉があるんですけれどもそこで講師も務めております
このように私
経営者
突っ張り棒が欠かせコンピュータのボールもで3つの
洛和会をやって言うんですけれども
こうやって色んな活動させていただいてすごく活発に活動しているように私なんですが
実はこのてレックスの舞台に参加することを紹介された時に雑誌自体ここで何を
しゃべったらいいのか
皆さんに向けて白できるか choo アイディアが何なのか全然分からなかったん
です
なぜここにいるのか分からなかったんです
私自身じゃあなんで思い浮かばないのか振り返ってみたんですね
そうすると気づいたんです
この3つの役割私どれも自分が望んでなった訳ではなかったんです
私はもともと今の会社に入り前
愚者をしていましたでも夢破れてっ
結果的にそのステージ国に求められている役割を全力で発行していたら結果的に
今の自分になっていました
一般的にまずはゴールを探しましょう
その夢に向かってじゃあ計画を立てて一旦
それを積み上げていったら絶対コールにたどり着くメガかなというふうに教えられて
いる場合が多いと思います
ですがわたしの場合は
そうではない方法で
私自身が一度自分がなくなりたいのかわからなくなった状態から
ん
今の状態にたどり着いています
私でた自身何を考えたいのかわからない状態から今に至っています
今日はですねこのように私自身がん
一度夢を失ってしまって夢を持たない常に何か状態からどうやっ
今に至っているのか皆さんお話ししたいと思っています
学生時代をさかのぼるぷ
そうは言えども私実は
ゴールに向かって一直線の人でした
やっぱりそう思うかもしれないんですけどこっからちょっと話が変わってきます
まずは私自身神戸向かって一直線でその当時は報道を通じて世の中を行くしたいと思っ
ていました
それで
報道機関新聞社テレビ局
q 通信社そのようなところだけに変更にして何とか1社内定をいただきました
そして晴れて新聞記者として報道も仕事に就くことができました
ですが
入社後壁にぶち当たります
会社の
正義と自分の正義
若くの特有な大草でその
磯現実のジャックに直面してたった3年で会社を辞めてしまいました
理想に燃えて者になった私にとってこれは大きなた雪でした
その後
道を失ってどうしようか悩んでいた時に父から
可能な入ってみないかと誘われました
これが辻なんですが
はじめはそのオファーを受け入れられなかったです
私のやりたいことと違うと思ってここはあったんですが数ヶ月考えて
一般の会社で働くことは私はなくてもできるけれども
父の会社で働くことというのは私に地下できること
私にしかできないとかもしれない
他に代わりがいない場所なのかもしれないそう思えるようになり
ん
家業に入る決意をしましたん
実際に入って見てどのような状態だったかというと
そしてこれが私にとってメーカー口が意味を持たずに飛び込んだ
初めての世界でした
実際に入ってみるとどうだったかと言いますと
事業
ジリ貧状態だ
先ほどお伝えしたように売り上げはピーク時の3分の1にまで落ちていました
ゲームつしてを持たない私であっても分かる
あまり良い状態ではありませんでした
永遠に私は記者しかいなかったので生地を変えて
発生していくそのことしか尽きる思っていませんでした
なんとか自分なりに会社を良くしたいと思って考えついたのがあっ
経営の知識を得るためにセミナーに参加するということでした
しまう
経験は時間をかけてしか得られないというのも
式であれば時間をかけなくとも自分の努力で何とかえっていることができるのではない
かと思っ
勉強に
勉強してみることにしましたそこで神戸大学の mba の授業です
その mba の授業参加で半年に凝縮して勉強できるという経営者向けのセミナーが
あるということをしに参加しました
この買ったひとつの行動が今の自分を作ることになります
この授業では
会社の状態がどうなっているのかまずフレームワークに沿って分析しました
ん
そのことによって会社の状態が決して良くないということがさらに詳しくわかりました
そこで今景気が出てるから出ている時期だからこそ新しい売上の柱くなるようなことを
しなければいけない
考え新規事業の立ち上げに追い出しました
そして会社の2つの支持を得られたり登録が得られたりする状態ではなかったですが
この米協会は次戦へ宿だったんですけれども
勉強会を通じて学ぶことができ
強い危機感を持っていたことを反対を押し切ってでも続けることができました
ん
強い5分にテイクが出たわけではありませんでした
この方向を取ったら
うまくいくんじゃないかこうやったら新しい事業になるんじゃないか
いろんなことを試してみましたん
そして
塾を熟考してからだいたい6年くらい買った後なんですけれども
ダブり粉という商品が生まれました
これはツッパリ気候を生かした diy 商品で
つっぱり機構のサップに引っ張り久喜高の茶っこ
木材もかかったはめると
やっぱりも同じ要領でピアノ分間の柱が建てられるというものです
それ以外にも泥払いという商品も開発しました
終わりですね
仲間を得ることができました
こちらも
左にいる人物なんですけどもっと用いてくれています
あげてはい運んで言う私の夫です
あの私がこの勉強会に参加したことがきっかけで私の夫もこの事業に参加し一緒に勉強
してもともか違う会社で働いていたのですが今では重い刑をして会社の課題に立ち
向かっています
それがにたくさんの知識ついて覚えてっ
この勉強会に参加したことがきっかけ
様々なチャンスをいただき今に至っています
そして私は今
酸っぱいボーを通じで多くの人を幸せにするということを実現することができました
ん
実はこれは
私が新聞記者を打ちにいっ
実現したかったことと結びついていました
何かというと
私は報道通じて秘湯車大手にすることがしたかったのですが
実はん
報道境方法で
それはすっぱり公という一番身近にあるもので私は多くの人を幸せにすることができた
んです
これは実は一度は夢がなくなってしまって何をしたらいいかわからない
もやもやの状態に合格していたんですけれども
それが菊花できっかけで結果的に私は責め
夢が叶っている状態になったということだったんです
までが私が夢を持たずに一度言えを無視星ないだからもう
自分の理想に統括したストーリーなんですがここから少し
皆さんもうどういうふうにやっていたのか糞席の部分を伝えしたいと思っています
一般的に
ゴールに向かってまずは自分をない関して
5分を明確にしましょうそこからゴールに向かって逆算して
計画を下に付いた手で夢を実現しましょう
それが裁判方法というふうに言われています
でも私の場合はそれはうまくいきませんでした
その代わりどうなったかというと
何をしたらいいのか分からない自分
得したいとかどこに行くも立つしたいのか目標顔定まらない
そういった状態に突入しました
それは決して楽なことではなくしんどい時期もありましたが
でも実はそれが私のチャンスに繋がりました
ん
自分の可能性というのを描けるのではなく
一度それを解放してあげることができ
何ができるのかチャレンジする機会を得ることができました
ん
この微笑むの状態になったかなんてか私はこの3つのことを取り組みました
そのことによって寿命を実現できました
まず思い込みをしてる
完璧な計画は練らない新しいことに挑戦する
者じゃないか夢は到達しないんじゃないか
その思い込みを捨てて
ゴールが見えないからこそこれがいいんじゃないか会えばいいんじゃないかという
あらゆる可能性を
試してみました
それを鈍化を繰り返すことによって徐々に自分の方向性
見えなかったん
高校生が輪郭が具体的に何を繰り返していくうちに新しい知識経験を得るようになる
自分のミクとなり
それがことを吹くない結果的に
やりたいことをやっていることのつじつまが合う瞬間というのに出会うことができまし
た
ん
ここまでだ私の夢を叶えて話になるのですよ
私は一度夢がなくなり
破れてしまったからこそ
この先などしたらいいのかわからないという状態になりました
ん
だからこそ
今まで減税していたこれじゃなきゃいけないと思っていた自分の可能性を開講して
あげることができました
そのことによっていっ
思い込みをせて新しいことにチャレンジしてん
自分新しい可能性をに挑戦することができました
この先の私もまだまだ
よりたくさんの方達の暮らしの幸せに貢献したいと思っていますが
それは豪華手段どういうことをしていったらいいのか
どんな状態をつくりたいのかまだまだ私はわからないことだらけです
でもこの8年間取り組んできたことでわかりました
今私が与えられていることを精いっぱいやっていけば精一杯
与えられたことにチャレンジしてしまう
きっとその先に5年10年後先に今の自分では想像もできないような自分で言ってやっ
てるんじゃないか
そう確信できています
この中にもきっともやばいを抱えている人は皆んじゃないでしょうか
もちろんゴールに向かって一直線それも素晴らしいことです
でも
もやもやしてたのって聞い
それも
きっかけ新しいことに出会えるチャンスだと私は思っています
だからこそ皆さん
自分の思い込み寄せデー
どんどん新しいことにチャレンジしていってください
そうすればきっと5年後10年後先に
今の自分では想像もできないような自分に出会えて焼いている瞬間に
狙って1週間を経験できると思います
ありがとうございました
[拍手]